hi there steve here again
continuing on my
korean challenge today i want to talk
about the importance of content
uh with reference to some of the
questions that i saw uh in response to
my last video or my recent videos uh
again if you enjoy these please
subscribe to my channel
also the conversation that i had with
hannah yesterday i looked at the
recording of it there was some static we
used a new microphone so
we may not be able to use that and i
will do another one in korean for those
of you who are interested in seeing my
progress in speaking korean
but uh you know content to my mind
interesting content whatever interests
you to me is is the the vital motor
driving us to learn the language because
we want to either we want to speak to
people we want to follow events on the
news we want to
whatever it might be it's our interest
that drives us
uh rather than the sort of deliberate at
least to me deliberate sort of learning
the details of the language is rather my
interest in something else and by
pursuing that i acquire the
language because to just learn the
grammar rules and so forth after a while
you're you're building in uh you know a
a castle in the sand in my opinion that
in fact you have to maintain and sustain
so much involvement with the language
that you need that interest to to keep
you going so having said that there were
some interesting comments which i'm
going to read here
one uh one heart nihon says that ask me
why i think fluency is achieved mainly
through speaking because fluency
typically describes not your reading
skill not your uh writing skill or your
listening comprehension skill it
describes your ability to speak that's
how we measure it now you need the
reading skill you need the listening
skill in order to achieve fluency
because you need to understand what
people are saying but to actually speak
fluently you need to practice you need
to speak a lot in my own case i prefer
to speak
more once i've acquired more words and
have a better ability to comprehend some
people like to start speaking early
whatever people want to do that's fine
but ultimately at some point you need to
speak a lot because you need to practice
that skill if you want to be considered
fluent and we went through the
definition of fluency
then someone also said that they are not
very interested in esperanto because
they didn't like the people or there was
no culture behind it i am also not
interested in esperanto but those people
who are interested in esperanto full
marks to them whatever people are
interested in uh i was expect the same
respect back that if i say i'm not
interested in esperanto the esperantist
should also respect that it's a matter
of pursuing your interests
and then i had a comment here
as
dave here says i don't understand why
you tackle texts way beyond your level
you're just reading complicated text
through the medium of english i don't
know what that means actually i'm
getting used to korean i don't think
there's any real merit in that apart
from it bolstering up bolstering is
enough actually bolstering up
your own ego in that you are reading
something high brow
i don't think political conversations on
this uh
uh
she saw whatever it was called sektanen
chison is highbrow
if you were in korea then surely you'd
have to learn more functional language
and do away with all the political
discussions if anything is very
difficult to steer conversations in that
direction in any language people simply
aren't that interested in having long
debates nor are they particularly
knowledgeable says dave and there's even
a person there who supports him gives
him a one thumb up dave continues steve
is in a privileged position that he will
never have to step outside his comfort
zone never
if he hadn't if he had to move to korea
then he could choose whom he entered who
he interacts with
choose where he wants to live because he
has the wealth behind him it's not to
say i don't admire him evidently he is
he clearly is a self-made man all i'm
saying is that steve's perspective is
from a wealthy retired businessman he
doesn't have to live the struggle of
finding work in the country dealing with
all the bureaucracy or setting up a bank
account in that country and he wouldn't
have to use the language for these
situations those that are generally
pressed to communicate do better than
those living in a homemade language
bubble of podcasts and novels
wow dave like
what is all that about um
you know whatever interests people in
learning a language they they should
pursue like i don't know german rock
hammerstein or mannerheim or whatever
there's some
ramstein or something lots of people
talk about this
german rock group that turns their crank
makes them keen to learn german good for
them i have zero interest in that uh
people learn japanese because they're
interested in anime people learn korean
because they're interested in korean
drama i can go on and on
for what i was motivated to read the
russian novels in the original russian
that was my initial motivation whatever
motivates people high bra low bra it
doesn't matter it's whatever your
interests are
that's point number one so i happen to
be interested in politics and history so
therefore i enjoy these podcasts
i understand them when i read them
i don't understand them particularly
well when i listen to them i understand
them better and better i am motivated
because it's natural conversation
and i like the voices so it's what turns
my crank how can that make dave upset i
don't understand
uh
it's not elitist and then he feels sorry
for himself because he lives in korea i
mean he doesn't spend the day
dealing with bureaucracy or setting up
bank accounts and i lived in japan and i
lived in france and there i had to do
those things in the language i never
felt sorry for myself in fact it's an
advantage because you are
because all of those situations are also
content it's it's a learning environment
the first time you go like i studied my
russian i went to saint petersburg went
to the train station thought i could ask
uh for how to buy a ticket to go to
viborg and the lady behind the counter
came at me with a whole bunch of stuff i
didn't know what she was saying
and but the second third fourth time
that i would face that situation that
context i would be comfortable because
you have to get used to whether it be
listening to political content or buying
something something in a store or buying
a ticket at the train station or dealing
with bureaucracy those are situations
where if you hadn't hadn't had them
before if you haven't had them before
you'll find them difficult and then you
get used to them you get used to them to
the point where you cannot even
anticipate what people are going to say
to you so you're ready with your answers
and so having that experience is great
if i lived in korea if or when i visited
korea i had the same i went into the
subways to try to use their subways and
some complicated system where you get a
deposit and stuff and i couldn't
understand i asked the
employee of the subway there and he
explained to me a mile a minute i didn't
understand a word he was saying but
after a while i spoke to some koreans i
figured out what their system was and
the next time around i'll be better
equipped to handle that situation i
don't see why that's a problem
you know this whole idea that we all
have to be interested in the same thing
we all have to have the same opinion we
don't have to have the same opinion
that's part of the problem i noticed
this when i attended i've mentioned this
before this
conference on dialoguing here at
in vancouver run by the simon fraser
university have a program for dialoguing
it's
the whole idea of dialoguing is that
everybody should feel the same way well
how about we disagree how about we have
different opinions
uh and respect different opinions and
defend our opinions
and
rather than taking down other people's
opinions and whether i'm a wealthy
retired businessman or not has nothing
to do with it you know my homemade
language bubble of podcasts and novels i
don't live in korea i can't i could go i
can go to the korean supermarket and i
do i go to the korean bookstore i go to
korean restaurants and i try to engage
them in korean sometimes the answer in
korean sometimes they answer in english
so
you know i can't i'm just
amazed that someone would would come out
with this sort of
you know
anti-elitist
anti-retired businessman woe is me i
live in korea
oh and this other thing that no one
talks politics lots of people are
interested in politics this uh podcast
that i doesn't do there's like four or
five
interviews every day with transcript
somebody's listening to those those are
popular podcasts in korea
in korea now somebody talks politics not
everybody has to talk politics i think
it's good to talk politics people should
be interested in how they're being
governed it affects lots in their lives
life isn't spent entirely setting up
bank accounts and dealing with
bureaucracy so i just find this whole
thing amazing and i really reiterate
that finding contra content of interest
for example
i in learning korea i cannot listen to
you know simple content where people
talk about three different ways of
saying something or what's the
difference between this expression and
that expression and five minutes are on
this subject with a lot of false
laughter and flaws false joviality and
english and stuff i can't listen to
those things but other people love them
because they're easier because they're
comfortable fine
my preference is to listen to something
that
i sense is interesting to me i don't
fully understand it and i'm motivated to
try to understand it what's wrong with
that so again i i just maybe got off on
a bit of a tangent here but i'm just
it's amazing to me that people think the
way this dave fellow does and that there
are people who come in and give him a
thumbs up so there you have it i expect
to hear back from dave
and pursue whatever interests you
in the language or in something else bye
for now